[Music]
question
Christian
[Music]
that doesn't mean I'm going to
listen
okay that
[Laughter]
wow I don't know if you guys caught that
like air hug right when the clock hit
zero that may be my favorite moment of
the night already love that welcome
welcome to the table my name is Karen
I'm part of the leadership team here and
if you're new what a great night to be
here cuz I'm new too we're all new here
this is our first Sunday in this new
location and it's beautiful I I feel
like I'm talking into a big cave
um it is it's such a big place but it
already I don't know about you guys it
already feels somewhat Like Home to me
it just has that welcoming atmosphere a
large part of that is thanks to First
saxi they're hosting us and yeah
[Applause]
we are so so grateful to them uh for
letting us rent this space and allowing
us to call this home to the table for
hopefully years to come as we grow and
we have new space for the kiddos which
is great um more space for us um so I'm
I'm feeling really really thankful
tonight very thankful so thank you for
being part of this historic evening as
well it's good to look out and see
familiar faces and new faces and um no
matter if you've been here a while or or
not long I hope that you feel welcomed
and at home here and free to be fully
yourself that's what we want so I have a
couple of announcements of things coming
up first of all does anybody know what
day it
is yes yes so this is the first Sunday
of the month and at the table on first
Sundays we go out to eat after the
service so you are all invited to go to
hat Creek Burger Company and that is the
location in saxi it's not too far from
here you'll just uh it's right on the
corner of 78 and Woodbridge where the LA
Fitness is it's just in front of the LA
Fitness so it's just a great way to go
beyond the walls of the church and
gather have a meal together continue
some conversation meet some people so I
hope you will join us at hat Creek
tonight that'll after the
service secondly and listen up because
this is important does anybody know what
next
Sunday yeah Super Bowl Sunday is next
Sunday so we are starting service an
hour earlier at 400 p.m. please remember
that 400 PM next Sunday so that you can
go home and enjoy the Super Bowl after
that we'll meet here it'll just be an
hour early please don't show up here at
5: because we'll be heading out and you
will have missed it so please remember
4M next Sunday just for next Sunday for
the Super Bowl then we'll be back on
track with our 500m services as normal I
am trying to make eye contact this is
like a wide a wide
range uh next February is Black History
Month yep so please keep your eye on the
table socials Instagram Facebook
throughout the month we'll be
highlighting people and organizations
that are doing good and needed work at
the intersection of racial Justice and
Christianity so make sure to keep an eye
on that and as always do your own
homework for Black History Month and
keep doing that all year long all right
how about if we take some time to just
quiet
ourselves close your eyes if you
like let's prepare our hearts for
worship and the message and this
evening take a deep breath if you
[Music]
like just take a moment to
arrive here
now set aside the
day set aside the week
[Music]
ahead let your heart and your
mind and your
body be
calmed listen to your
[Music]
heartbeat feel yourself
grounded and
alive and
loved pray with
me God thank you for tonight thank you
for this place and these
people God I thank
you for anyone who has shown up here
tonight feeling
vulnerable maybe
nervous God I pray that they would be
surrounded by love and encouragement and
support and a sense of
Home Jesus help us Center on you tonight
remembering that you are the source of
Hope and
peace and love especially when things
are swirling around
us God be our Center our home our source
and help us to know that we are loved
beyond anything we can
imagine in Jesus name
amen amen thank you Karen so good to
look out and see you guys in this space
with us we are so excited if y'all would
stand with us we're going to get started
I really quickly wanted to say a thank
you I know like Jesse's getting us going
in this first song but um um you guys
I've been like down down down for the
count for like 10 days with the flu and
my team stepped in on two Sundays
filling in the gaps for so so many
dropped balls so many unanswered texts
so many things picking up leading for me
feeling and so many of you reached out
and I just wanted to say like that is
what community feels like is when people
like swoop in when you're at your lowest
and they um show up for you so I'm just
I'm grateful for this team and I wanted
to say that in front of you guys how
thankful I am for them and for all of
you so anyway we're glad y'all are with
us we're going to kick off this Sunday
with the first song that we kicked off
at Pleasant Valley when we first started
the table um because this is one of
those anchor songs for us that reminds
us of our cause um it's about love it's
about connecting with a God who has made
space for each one of us so let's sing
it together all
[Music]
right
ring the bells this time I mean it bid
the hatred fairly well give back the
pieces of my Jesus Take Your counterfeit
to Hell bang the drums This Means War
not the kind you Wai for we say Mercy
won't be rationed here that's what we're
fighting
for all is sp in Ling more what the hell
is loving even
for
if we can't sing it loud enough we'll
keep oning voices
up ring the
bells ring the
bells move your feet you tiny people
you've been hiding for so long behind
your statues and your Steeples does that
hit too close to home
I got faith to move a mountain and to
watch that mountain move it's time for
words to fall like thunder sound of
Justice breaking
through all this loing war the world the
hell ising even
[Music]
for the world laughs and the modesty BL
breaks through the
Cal ring the bells
ring the
bells ring the
bells you call me a boy instead of son
and I ain't the only one was in the
throne room of the Kingdom where I found
that I belong I ain't scared to face the
Fortress I have seen them fall before
with broken bones you built it but
crumbles for my Bo
there in Ling for what the hell is Ling
even
[Music]
for if we can't sing it loud enough
we'll keep on let
voices ring the
bells ring the
bells ring the bells this time I mean it
bid the hatred fairly well give back the
pieces of my Jesus Take Your counterfeit
to
hell all
right you kiddos are dismissed to go to
your new classrooms down this
hallway and there will be instructions
from your teachers on which way to go
line up at the doors L up at the
do love
it bye guys we'll see you
after all
right um the teachers are going to walk
those kiddos to the class so they are
not um they're not off on their own just
trying to find their way they do have
teachers out there that will show them
the way thank you so much to our kids
ministry um we are really excited to be
in a new space that can better serve our
kids and um what a blessing that is
because they are a gift to this
community we're going to go ahead and
transition into the prayers of the
people so if you guys um would join me
in praying this aloud and as usual
whenever we get to the open space if you
would just speak out whatever you're
caring into this room whether it's a
person or a situation that's Weighing on
your heart tonight we want to hold that
before God together believing that he
hears us and he is with us all right so
let's pray this out for this city of
saxi Texas and for every city and
community and all who live in them we
pray to you for the Good Earth you have
given us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us and so we lift these
names and situations up to
[Music]
you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
[Music]
amen
sing these words
together God we bring you the work of
our hand now lay it down lay it at your
feet what we''ve done what we built what
we
broken lay it down lay it at your
feet you
hold it
all Jesus you
hold
[Music]
all
worried Hearts weed hands weakened
bodies lay it down lay it at your
feet what we've used what we've lost
what we'
was lay it down lay it at your
feet you
hold it all Jesus you hold
it
all you
hold it
all Jesus you hold it
[Music]
oh all our dreams all our plans our
ambition
lay it down lay it at your
feet and even if nothing comes to
fruition lay it down lay it at your
feet you
hold it all Jesus you
hold it
all you hold it
it all Jesus you hold it
[Music]
all God we bring you the work of our
hands now lay it down lay it out at your
feet what we usew what we buil what we
broken lay it down lay it at your
feet lay it down lay it
at your
feet
[Music]
I'm caught up in your
presence I just want to sit here at your
feet caught up in this
holy
moment I never want
[Music]
leave oh I'm not here for
blessings Jesus you don't know
me
anything more than anything
that you can
do I just want
[Music]
you I'm
sorry when I've just gone through the
motions I'm
sorry I'll just sing another song take
me back to where where we
started I open up my heart to
[Music]
you I'm
sorry I come with my agenda I'm
sorry when I forget that you're enough
take me back to where we start
I open up my heart to
[Music]
you I just want
you nothing
[Music]
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing else
nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will do oh I just
want nothing
else
nothing
else nothing else will
do
W
woo
W nothing else will do W I just
want wo
w
oh nothing else will do
[Music]
oh I'm CAU up in your
presence I just want to sit here here at
your
feet I'm CAU up in this
holy
morning I never W
leave oh I'm he
blessing Jesus you don't know me
anything
[Music]
more than
anything that you can
do I just want
you I just
[Music]
you nothing else will
do
[Music]
nothing
else nothing
else nothing else to
do I just
[Music]
want I'm C up in your
presence I just want to sit here at your
feet up
holy
moment never
[Music]
want God would you me us here in this
moment sometimes we feel so close to you
it feels like you're literally in front
of us or holding
us or experiencing the joys with
us and then sometimes it feels like it's
so hard to connect so hard to reenter
ourselves into who you created us to be
we build our walls and we wear our
masks we tell ourselves everything's
fine we run from our pain we
self-medicate we choose things that are
other than what you would have
us to
[Music]
be choose things other than what you
would have us to live
we choose temporary
Joys fleeting
attractions but God what I found is that
every time no matter where I run no
matter how far I feel from you God in
the end what I want is to come back
home to come back to the center of Who
You Are and who I am inside of
you so tonight God would you reconnect
us would you regraft Us in to your
[Music]
family would you show us our seat at the
table would you make room for us God
show us where it is that we've run away
from but where we will find all of our
life and all of our purpose all of our
joy and our
hope right inside of your
[Music]
love God help us to come back
home to make a space a home for
[Music]
others thank you for who you are
there's nothing else that we
want thank you for this time
together we are grateful for it and it's
in your name that I pray
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you and just extend welcome and
love to them um then Brett will get us
started with our
message
all right well Grace and peace it is so
good to be with you all all of you all
of y'all showed up for this first Sunday
this is great
hey yeah that's awesome I um I know next
week's the Super Bowl all that so it'll
probably be a little different that's
okay don't worry I'm not I'm not bitter
it's fine it's fine um and no but I
really am I'm just yeah I'm grateful
grateful to um to be in this space um
with all of you and um if this is your
first time or maybe just your first time
in a long time um we're really really
glad that that you're here with us on uh
what obviously is a a really significant
day in the um just the life of our
community and I have um so many people I
could thank I do want to just mention a
few names um Gary Miner Josh Rollins
with tech Caitlyn's back there Marissa's
back there um can you all give them a
[Music]
hand
as as you can imagine coming into a new
space for the first time it's just kind
of a lot um especially on the tech side
you know kind of like and we didn't
exactly get like a big test run you know
um and so it's yeah they've done really
amazing and um of course Marissa with
setup tear down Raymond with First
Impressions Dawn on Hospitality the
entire kids team which is like Maggie
and Anna and Britney and Angie and Kelly
and like I mean just there's like a
whole crew um
and then of course Mindy the worship
team like just give them all a hand
yeah as um as we'll get into in the
message you'll see like it really is it
is about the community it is about what
what the holy spirit is doing in and
Among Us um together and oh how just how
beautiful yeah so all that to say my
heart is full my heart is full on this
day and uh I what I want to kind of name
here is this has from the beginning it
has felt like a really significant um
transition in the life of our community
and what I mean is like in a way that's
maybe more man I got so much space I can
just wander all over just in a way
that's bye goodbye and then like oh see
you you um like in a way that it has
felt like more than just like oh well
it's a change of location and that's
significant and you know ho it's like we
we're there and now we're here and
that's cool that's cool um it's it's
really has um it's felt like a shift
from chapter
one into chapter two and the truth is uh
I'm kind of tempted to try and outline
like what all that means and but the
truth is I don't know I don't quite I
don't you know surprise I don't know the
future um so I don't I don't know
exactly what that means but that is what
I'm what I've been feeling we been
talking about as a um Elder leadership
team and just that's kind of the the
sense so with that in mind what I wanted
to do kind of in this message is uh kind
of have it be like a little bit of a
reflection time where we think really
seriously like who are we becoming which
is the title of my message who are we
becoming and I had a subtitle that I
edited out but now I'm prompted to say
it um three questions for the table on
what feels like a significant Sunday
that was my uh that was my subtitle that
I took out um and so yeah that's kind of
way I'm going to frame it just three
questions and we'll just kind of walk
through some of these um so question
number one is church for the
people or are people for the
church and in other words
are is is the institution like is it
working on behalf of the people or at
some point do we get a little bit wonky
and suddenly it's like the people are
just there to preserve uphold ensure the
institution tion itself continues to
flourish you know to um kind of put it
crash you might say to uh to like keep
the machine running which we'll kind of
get into a little bit more in um Point
number two this first one though I'm
thinking this is probably a little more
applicable for myself um for the leaders
at the table uh you
know let's be
careful that we don't get that switch on
because it's amazing how quickly that
happens like before you even know it I
mean it's not you
like you start you set out to like hey
let's start the table it's going to be
great and we'll just like everyone and
you know what could go wrong and before
you know it it gets it's weird it just
somehow it just things get twisted uh I
was reminded of there's a a stunning
story M Mark chapter 2: 23- 27 um it
says one Sabbath Jesus was going through
the grain Fields uh and as his disciples
walked along they began to plug some
heads of grain the Pharisees said to him
uh look why are they doing what is
unlawful on the Sabbath he answered have
you never read what David did when he
and his companions were hungry and in
need in the days of abathar the high
priest he entered the house of God and
ate the consecrated bread which is
lawful only for priests to eat and he
also gave some to his companions and
then he said to them the Sabbath here's
the key line the Sabbath
was made for people not people for the
Sabbath and
um you know can you see where this like
this is a great example like if you
would think of anything that like
religious institutions couldn't mess up
it would be the Sabbath like hey
everyone day
off you know like it just sounds like
great this is this is for human
flourishing let's just ensure that we
all take a day to rest you're like what
could go wrong wrong and again but this
is kind of what happened by the time uh
Jesus is on the earth like suddenly it
got all weird there's like all these
rules because they really want to line
out like well what does that mean like
not to work and before you know it it's
like so regulated and then they're kind
of looking around like judging people
like uhhh you're breaking the Sabbath
you're breaking the Sabbath too you know
and you can see where all of a sudden
you go from this thing that's meant to
be so lifegiving so amazing and before
you know it uh it's all weird in fact in
the very um next
chapter uh Jesus that he runs into the
Pharisees again and they have this issue
around the Sabbath and this time it's
because Jesus wants to heal
someone and the religious leaders
they're like wait wait wait are you
thinking of healing that guy and Jesus
is like yes I'm thinking very seriously
about it and they're like uh uhuh uh
uh-uh uh-uh cuz you are a wonder
worker and that's your
work you you're a miracle worker that's
your work so you can't do that on the
Sabbath and Jesus is like watch
me and of course he heals the man um but
can you see where like and Jesus
actually ends up asking this sort of
rhetorical question like um is it now
against the the law to do good on the
Sabbath is that is that where we've kind
of come
to
so you can see where that's an an
example of a religious kind of Rhythm uh
a way of
being that is like starts off good and
then gets twisted and what I'm kind of
contending is that that's what's true
for the Sabbath that's true for like any
religious practice institution mean
prayer can this can happen to prayer you
know it's like oh it's beautiful just
just being with God you know but before
you know it it's like all weird and
wonky and you feel pressure and guilty
if you don't
and like and and what's true of
religious practices of course is true
for religious
institutions right that the very thing
meant to to encourage and uplift and
bring life all of the sudden it's like
not about that anymore I want to give
you a few kind of signs of like uhoh
things are starting to get wonky here um
first would be clergy
entitlement this sense that pastors can
start getting I'm picking on myself here
where it's like this idea of like well
you you all are here for
me like what a
ridiculous stupid thing like I mean does
any Pastor go into the ministry with
that mindset I mean it would be
psychotic it would be the craziest thing
and yet what happens I don't know things
drift and
some sort of resentment or and suddenly
it's like what you're here for me you're
supposed to make right so it can be that
it can look like um just plain
burnout that's this not just clergy but
I'm talking like kind of you know where
it's there's just this like we need
more the machine needs
more the institution it needs more more
from you more energy and more finances
and more just more more just more of
everything you know I hope your anxiety
is not spiking right now um you know you
can kind of feel like and and maybe
you've been in places where that starts
to kind of creep in and and I'm not just
picking on other places I'm saying
that's a danger that's and again I think
our hearts start off good it's like no
but but it's because we want to reach
people we want all the good thing you
know yeah somewhere along the way it's
like you you lose your I don't know you
lose reminded of a is it David bazon I
don't quite how to say his last name um
who has a a song in his line I know he
was uh someone who kind of went through
pretty intense deconstruction and left
Christian faith and all that and the
line that's coming back to me is um
you you he says I used to feel like um
The Prodigal Son
returning um and then the line is but
now um now you just hate the thing
you've made and you want to watch it
burn and those are two lines they're
separate from each other but those are
two lines from the psalm that stand out
to me and I'm not continuing I'm not
saying like and I let the table burn I'm
not saying that um I'm saying boy
wouldn't that be sad if like that's
where we ended up you know where it's
like the very thing you start off
loving and then before you know you're
just like h
like the spirit's gone out of the place
like what
happened like
y'all let's don't go that
road let's don't go that
road I might sum it up by saying when a
church becomes more focused on
preserving itself than serving and
loving one
another it's lost the plot you know all
right so that's the first question um
second question will we get too busy
running the church to be the
church and this you can feel where it's
similar I think the first questions kind
of aimed like I said a little more at me
and kind of leadership and I would say
this one's sort of for all of us um I'll
start here I'll be honest as like a
really um young Church planner so for
those who don't know some my story this
is our second um church plan as a really
young Church planner I'll be honest like
the thing I wanted above all like I
wanted both boatloads of people I did in
fact I'll be doubly
honest I still kind of want boatloads of
people you know like I mean it's it's
fun you know what I mean like I mean
heck the energy today like all of y'all
here like GE oh my God you know it is
and and there's something beautiful
about like I don't think you know
growing bad like no there's something
beautiful in that and you know hooray
that that is it's wonderful um but the
longer I'm kind of on the Pastor on this
journey the longer I can see that boy
that's just not where the magic
is like in in essence um well when I say
the magic I'm thinking um well actually
I'll get to what the magic is I'll say
right now what it's not like there's
this kind of uh again another little
crude saying in the in the ministry the
way we say it in the ministry is uh it's
known as the four bees anyone know the
four bees uh buts and SE
baptisms budgets and buildings that's
the four
BS and you can see where I think people
equate the magic with that you know like
hey well that's when you know it's
working that's a Spirits you know I
remember when I um was a youth pastor
back in the day and we went through this
weird actually we a church got into a
new building and so we became kind of
the cool youth group in town which is
honestly just a sociological phenomenon
like it's just you know the teens just
follow each other so they all just go
it's sort of like winter take all in
youth ministry you know um and so we
just happened to be that I but people
were like oh my goodness the spirit is
just there wow you're so anointed you
know I was
like I don't I don't think so actually I
I think we're just cool for That season
and truth be
told which was a cool one we didn't grow
at all like we're just small you know
like nothing um in other words focused
on the wrong
things and we just get all wonky and
sideways with this and I'm just I'm kind
of imagining you know 10 years from now
where could the you know who will we
become what what if the the table oh my
goodness we like own building or you
know Pastor Brett's fulltime we have
other pastors on you know whatever and
people like wow what a success you know
but I'm just imagining like what if all
that happens but like deep down we
know like our best days were like 2
24 like how tragic would that be because
it's not just about the four like it's
fine but no the Magic The Magic is
something
different it is it it's and it is it's a
mystery which I love how Richard or
defines mystery not as things are
unknowable but as endlessly knowable
you know and there is there's some mster
it's it's the something with with God
that's insightful it has something to do
with god um glad you write that down you
know
um it yeah it's it's God it's uh the
love people have for one another it's a
certain self-sacrifice a um even I think
a kind of emotional healing and in a
path people have to be on towards some
inner hold so that they're not just so
lost in their own pain they can actually
look out but something there's something
beautiful that happens there you know
and um oh I don't I don't want us to
lose that and in fact I want us to like
grow into it cultivate it there's a a
beautiful passage Matthew 25 um 31-40
very intense passage from Jesus um quite
surprising where he says this um when
the son of man comes in his
glory and all the angels with him he'll
sit on his glorious Throne all the
nations will be gathered before him and
he will separate the people one from
another as a Shepherd separates the
sheep from the goats yall remember this
passage like oh my goodness it's so
powerful he will put the sheep on his
right the goats on his left and the King
will say to those on his right come come
you who are blessed by my father take
your inheritance the kingdom prepared
for you since the creation of the world
for I was hungry and you gave me
something to eat
I was thirsty you gave me something to
drink I was a
stranger you invited me
in I needed clothes and you clothed me I
was sick and you looked after me I was
in prison and you came to visit me and
then the righteous will answer him I
love that they don't realize what they
were
doing righteous will answer him Lord
when when did we see you hungry and feed
you or thirsty and give you something to
drink when did we see you a stranger and
invite you in or needing clothes and
clothe you when did we see you sick or
in prison and go to visit you the king
will reply truly I tell you whatever you
did for one of the least of these
brothers and sisters of mine you did for
me and then of course he goes on to say
to those on his left uh depart from me
there's a whole kind of doctrine of how
we can get into for those who've been at
the table you know I don't think of hell
as Eternal conscious torment I don't
think he's saying depart from me forever
and you shall be tortured and I hate you
I don't think it's that um but do you
think there was some he feeling that was
going to have to happen in their souls
and of course they're shocked too
they're just like whoa whoa whoaa
what what do you mean like because and I
think the reason they'd be shocked is
because parameters of the Judgment I
mean how surprising is that passage like
this is what surprises me is that it's
not the things we often think of you
know what I mean it's not
like you're on my right so yall win you
know come into the kingdom D the ghosts
are here um you know and and it's not
and what's the basis of it's not because
you walked this aisle right here you
walked this aisle and you said Jesus and
I said okay you're saved brother you um
it's not like because you were baptized
in the proper theological manner you
know whatever that is uh it's not that
is
it like it's it's nothing that almost
that church folks tend to really harp on
you know or get obsessed over what is it
it's I was there
I was hiding I was in every vulnerable
person you ever saw I was there did you
see
me did you did you even
notice did you have time to
listen can you see where this happens in
church we get so busy we get so caught
up in whatever the four bees or whatever
boy you know like we just get lost and
we we stop seeing the people like around
us the vulnerable
ones tonight there are vulnerable ones
in our
midst and in fact it's not even like a
static thing like there's a group of
people and they are vulnerable and
they're forever vulnerable you know it's
not that there are seasons where all of
us become the vulnerable ones Mental
Health
crisis death in the family know whatever
it is like we're going through and all
of a sudden job loss like we were on top
of the mountain and then we are like oh
my gosh my world is
crumbling and and I think Christ is
going to ask like did you have the eyes
to see one
another when they were at their most
vulnerable and it's not just about the
church I mean you'll notice this even
the context of this passage isn't I mean
you can kind of interpret these brothers
and sisters of mine is that you know the
the kingdom of God Community or is it
Beyond on these
walls well we get so busy running the
church doing the church the thing that
we like start to miss miss the heart of
it and of course what's true for us you
know individually it's it's true for us
collectively um will we have the eyes to
see people in that
way uh third
question what if we learned to love God
instead of fearing
God what if we learn to love God instead
of fearing God and here's what I have in
mind I know we could kind of go into the
what the fear of the Lord is the
beginning of wisdom and you know I've
touched on that before um I don't I
don't think that's a cringing Terror of
God um is the beginning of wisdom you
know I think
um well maybe the way I I'll frame It Is
by saying um there's so so many folks
here who come to the table that are
coming from very um kind of conservative
fundamentalist
backgrounds and our image of God we
touched on this last week and I'll
continue to touch on it is just so like
messed up where we're
like God God has just become this kind
of force of
Terror this hurtful slightly abusive
not sure how he's going to feel
today kind of God and then the preacher
gets up and is like we got to love the
Lord you know we got to love God you
know it's almost this idea where we love
Jesus we're just not sure about his dad
you
know
he's you know Jesus is so
nice
but oh those there's those other
passages you
know it's a it is a it is like legit it
is a tremendous tremendous problem um
and I think I just I I just I
long I long for us to love God but I
know for that to happen we're going to
have to keep finding some some healing
there and I think I want to say two
things to that one is if you're in that
place where you need to find some
healing in that it is okay take your
time don't take this point as like me
saying hurry it up you know um take the
space you need take the time you need um
but at the same time my point to you
would be um but keep going keep moving
because there's people here could who
could who have been in your shoes been
in that place and we can tell you that
if you just stay on the journey like you
can get to a place where you really do
trust down to your toes that that God is
every bit as nice as Jesus and in fact
what Jesus said is true that if you've
seen me Christ said you've seen the one
he called father you've seen God like
there's no
difference uh 1 John chapter 4 uh speaks
to this and so we know and rely on the
love God has for us God is love whoever
lives in love lives in God
in God in them this is how love is made
complete among us so that we will have
confidence on the day of judgment in
this world we are like Jesus there is no
fear in love but perfect love drives out
fear because fear has to do with
punishment and the one who fears is not
made perfect in love in other words as
long as we still live in fear of God we
have not yet learned to love God
as long as we still live in fear in
cringing Terror of
God we're we're just still learning how
to
love I came across a um just a quote
that completely caught me off guard this
week um from a a gentleman named rert I
don't know how to say his last name spir
I think um but he he put it like this he
said God wants one thing from
us our happiness
amen God wants one thing from us our
happiness I'm curious as to how that
hits you you know for some of us maybe
have a hard time with that like well
what no what God wants from us is
Holiness he wants the Holiness and he
wants us to get on the right track and
clean up our act you know
um not no because because what he's
naming here is not just like a sort of
silly pleasure like let's just be you
know happy like no but uh
peace
Joy when you have that like love
flows Holiness flows goodness
flows you don't have to worry about all
that like Focus
here heal
here I want to close with this quote
from um St Augustine who I think in his
later years was well he disappointed me
in his later years but his early years I
think that's some of his best stuff this
is from his book confessions and uh in
fact what I want to invite you to do
just go ahead and like close your eyes
and listen to this this passage he says
oh late have I loved you oh Beauty Ever
ancient ever new late have I loved you
you were within me but I was outside and
it was there that I searched for you in
my un liness I I plunged into the lovely
things which you
created you were with me but I was not
with
you created things kept me from you yet
if they had not been in you they would
not have been at all you called you
shouted you broke through my deafness
you flashed you Shone and you dispelled
my blindness you breathed your fragrance
on me I drew in breath and now I pant
for you I have tasted you and now I
hunger and I thirst for more you touched
me and I burned for your
peace in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen
so we come to table of the Lord tonight
as we take in the body of Christ in the
bread the blood of Christ in the wine
may it be a moment of reentering for all
of
us may it be a moment where our image of
God is healed as we literally we we take
in God so to speak we
reconnect with the one who made us and
loves us
unconditionally so that's my that's my
heart for kind of the spirit in which
I'd like us to take communion tonight so
the way we'll do this um if you've been
with us for a while um it will honestly
be very similar we're going to continue
to just kind of go row by row and work
our way back um we'll kind of form one
line right here in the middle um the one
difference will be that we're going to
have two people um serving the wine so
one person with the bread and then
person on either side of them with the
cup that way you can kind of go off in
the direction you know you need to so if
you're sitting over here obviously you
can kind spin off that way um or that
way uh we practice what's called an open
meaning if you're here tonight and you
have something a desire to participate
you're like I don't know if I believe
all the right things or I don't don't
know am I the right denomination or
whatever you know if you're here and you
want to connect with the Risen Christ um
then you you are welcome to come forward
um you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and uh then finally
terms of how to partake again we won't
lead you through that moment we now have
plenty of space up here and actually you
might it's four why are there pillows at
the front um that's so that you can come
and kneel as you partake um so you don't
have to do that but if you'd like to
just take a moment and be able to kind
of kneel um have a moment with God you
can there's even a little kind of holder
where you can put your empty Cup right
there um so you can take that way you
could also just um take immediately um
there's trash cans that are going to be
kind of on either side that you can put
your cup in and um and then we'll kind
of close with this with this last song
so uh this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
[Music]
table
you
[Music]
I
on
[Music]
come
time
[Music]
we're going to close tonight with um a
song that we've never done before and uh
to me it feels like a true benediction
um and and later Karen will come and
she'll release us with another
benediction but I just wanted us to sing
this along together tonight um if you
will just stand with us and the words to
the song I have found to be so very
relatable to our Human Experience so
very
honest um that in all things though as
followers of Jesus we are asking him to
come and be part of each moment each day
each each uh high and low would he meet
us there would we carry him with us so
would you guys sing that as a prayer
tonight as we close out
together
and my work takes me places I don't want
to
go Christ
has me and my heart aches with sorrow as
I hit the road
Christ be with me when the care of my
family takes all that I have Christ
within me when I'm MN and exhausted
ashamed that I'm M
Christ
[Music]
me
I Rise up today in a strength that is
not on my
[Music]
own I'm held by the promise of God that
I'm never
[Music]
alone when I'm tossed to the side and I
want to give up
Christ
when I'm breaking my back but it's never
enough
Christ
beside me when I work hard but someone
else gets the
reward God I see me and I ask for
promotion and they shut the
door Christ ears hear
me I Rise up today in a strength that is
not on my
own I'm held by the promise of God that
I'm never
[Music]
alone I climb the first steps a
long
Christ above me I leap out in faith and
I hope to find Wings Christ
beath
[Music]
me
there we go all right thank you so much
sorry I got something in my throat thank
you for being with us
tonight you being here enriches our
community and I hope you know that I
hope you feel that and I hope you feel
at home
here um if you need prayer PR a hug
somebody to talk to I would love to be
there for you however I can so after
service you can come find me let's say
that plant over there I'll be right next
to the plant you can come find me over
there also if you are visiting us
tonight please take a moment before you
leave to fill out a visit feel like this
is going in and out uh a visitor card
either by scanning the QR code up on the
screen screens or you can grab a visitor
card over at that table over there Jeff
can you raise your hand over by Jeff we
have visitor cards over there you can
fill one out drop it in the box or you
can go online and do it with the QR code
up
there also love being a community that
is open and affirming and inclusive and
motivated by love so believe in our
vision and in our mission and want to
join us please consider giving
financially you can same places either
using the QR code up on the screens or
over at the table on your way out also
we kids checkin and checkout system so
after service make sure you have your
sticker go to where you checked your kid
or kids in and that's where you will
pick up your kiddos okay and if you have
any questions find one of us
all
right huh
yeah hello
hello I'm really throwing Josh for a
loop I'm sorry but I think this one is
working cool all
right um don't forget that next week we
are meeting at what time 4:00 for Super
Bowl Sunday and also hat Creek as soon
as we're done with the service on the
corner of 78 in Woodbridge in the same
parking lot as LA Fitness please go join
us it's always fun at Haack cre and they
have great food and we'll get a chance
to talk to you and see one
another all right you're already
standing to your feet which is great
it's time for our benediction and if
you've never heard this benediction I
want you to know that these words were
written especially and specifically for
this community so if you are hearing my
voice these words are for
you you can hold out your hands in a
posture of receiving you can close your
eyes or just open your
heart you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
Lowe's and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of compassion and Grace and love
to everyone you come in contact with
have a good
night hope to see you back here next
week at 4:00 don't forget to go to hat
cream you are loved good
night I Rise up today in a strength that
is not on my
own
[Music]
I'm held by the promise of God that I'm
never
alone oh I Rise
iise I Rise up today in a strength that
is not on my
own I'm held by the promise of God that
I'm never
alone
when I climb the first steps toward the
long H
dream
Christ
above I leap out in faith and I hope to
find Wings Christ
beeath
me